bonjour à toutes et à tous en ce nouvel
an nouvelle année 2021 je vous souhaite
évidemment tous mes voeux de santé et de
dynamisme ainsi qu'à vous jimmy est
ainsi qu à vous notre invité béatrice
bel et bonjour aux gens mais c'est qu'un
juge bonjour à tous les auditeurs
martinique 1ère voilà bonne année 2021 à
vous aussi vous êtes la première
secrétaire de la fédération socialiste
de la martinique et nous y viendrons
également au cours de cet entretien
puisque depuis la fin de l'an dernier
vous êtes membre du secrétariat national
du parti socialiste du ps dont le
premier secrétaire est toujours olivier
faure il a été renouvelé pour ce mandat
et vous vous êtes secrétaire nationale
chargée de l'égalité réelle mais voilà
nous nous y reviendrons 2021 donc
nouvelle année qui semble commencer
moins mal que comme 2020 c'est terminé
est-ce que vous béatrice bel et vous
avez une certaine dose d'optimisme
notamment avec les vaccins qui arrivent
pour ce début d'année
je vais commencer quand même aussi par
part souhaité à tous les martiniquaises
à toutes les martiniquaises être les
martiniquais des voeux de bonne santé
évidemment et puis oui des voeux de
d'espoir parce que il faut que nous
restions plein d'espoir sur la suite des
événements avec en effet des solutions
qui sont apportés qu'elles soient
médicamenteuse ou vaccinale et qu'il
conviendra en est de 2,2 de mettre à
profit en tout cas de la santé de nos
concitoyens
avant de parler de la campagne de
vaccination de la façon dont elle
pourrait se dérouler ici aussi en
martinique quel est votre avis votre
position de responsables politiques par
rapport à vos vaccins d'une manière
générale et à ce vaccin là en
particulier
j'ai du mal aujourd'hui à mesure oui bah
écoutez alors il ya des doutes légitimes
et puis il ya des espoirs légitimes
également les doutes légitimes c'est de
se poser des questions en effet sur sur
la qualité les effets de ces vaccins sur
sur les populations
et puis les espoirs légitimes c'est
naturellement sont que ça va permettre à
priori de guérir ou en tout cas de
permettre de ne pas développer des
signes graves de duke au vide de la côte
19 donc de près de deux millions de
personnes vaccinées maintenant dans le
monde alors on parle la campagne va va
continuer est ce que ça veut dire quand
même qu'on peut commencer à peut-être
faire un peu confiance finalement au
scientifique d'abord il fait confiance à
la science à la première personne que je
vais aller voir cesser mon médecin et je
lui demander conseil
eu égard au fait que c'est lui qui me
connaît mieux je crois qu'il faut avoir
cette démarche
cette démarche de confiance à l'endroit
de nos scientifiques et de ceux qui font
de la recherche et il faut demander
conseil à ceux qui connaissent le mieux
notre état de santé et la science est un
vaccin ça peut avoir des effets
secondaires mais sur le principe un
vaccin c'est censé sauver les personnes
et protéger ces populations mais donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai dit enfin vous
savez tous les vaccins
et tous les médicaments peuvent avoir
des effets secondaires donc il faut
juste savoir si ils sont graves ou s'ils
sont adaptés aussi à notre état de santé
et je crois que le meilleur les
meilleurs correspondant pour ça ce sont
nos mecs à un avis plutôt favorable
comme dans la vie un avis prudent mais
tu n'es pas un avis négatif je crois
qu'on a le droit de se poser des
questions et des questions légitimes
la campagne de vaccination devrait
débuter d'ici quelques jours en
martinique on annonce les premières
vaccinations pour la fin de la semaine
ce dimanche
je crois peut-être dans certains ehpad
comment doit-elle se dérouler ici
comment vous voyez les choses pour ces
défauts graves
je crois que le plus important compte
tenu la de la méfiance qui qui a été
dévoilée par rapport à 7 par rapport à
ce virus et deux à cette vaccination
je crois qu'il va falloir continuer la
pédagogie et l'information sur le vaccin
et puis probablement en effet le
proposer parce que il faut que les
personnes aient le choix
le proposer aux personnes les plus
fragiles et celles qui ont le plus de
risques d'avoir une fin létale si elle
bat la lll sont contaminés donc je crois
que le les priorités ont été fixées de
façon nationale sur les personnes âgées
dix mille doses pour la martinique en
tout cas pour commencer pour la première
phase
bon ça signifie évidemment que dans un
premier temps toute la population ne ne
sera pas validé vous avez 10 25 et 30
sont d'abord les personnes âgées les
personnes effectivement qui ont qui sont
de santé fragile les personnels
soignants etc
donc il y aura des ordres de priorité
béatrice bellay première secrétaire de
la fédération socialiste de la
martinique est également secrétaire
national au ps en charge de l'égalité
réelle de la politique de l'égalité
réelle
cette crise sanitaire c'est l'occasion
un collectif a fait une tribune dans le
monde
là je croyais aujourd'hui me semble que
c'est dans l'édition d'hier repenser le
système de santé le plus
démocratiquement possible bon afin
d'affronter des crises du 21e siècle
c'est ça met donc un collectif de
personnalités issues du milieu médical
ou de la recherche
regroupés au sein de l'institut santé
appelle donc dans une tribune à une
réforme du système de santé
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous dit
effectivement j'ai j'appelle souvent à
la mémoire et je crois que il ya moins
d'un an et demi nous étions dans la rue
sur les moyens donnés à la santé les
moyens donnés à l'hôpital dont je crois
la mia robot définitivement déjà
commencé mais même voilà exactement et
depuis bien avant
d'ailleurs cette cette pandémie donc je
crois qu'il ya réellement des visions à
la réforme en matière de santé
aujourd'hui le système de santé a été
financiarisé donc on regarde combien ça
rapporte et combien ça coûte je crois
que l'essentiel aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir comment on soigne est-ce qu'on
soigne bien ce qu'on accueille bien est
ce que on a un système de santé partout
qui peut une offre de santé qui peut en
tout cas chez nous notamment être
suffisante pour la population et
répondre à ses besoins
donc oui il ya probablement de façon
très démocratique parce que c'est la
dimension data titrisation citoyenne qui
devrait aussi alors participation
citoyenne ne peuvent pas répondre à
toutes les questions mais en tout cas
démocratique au sens où la réflexion
doit être collégiale et elle ne doit pas
rester au simple niveau probablement
d'un de gouvernement et avec plus
peut-être aussi de d'implication de la
part des territoires finalement avec
beaucoup plus tôt oui mais j'aimerais
concentration une généralisation mais je
le rappelle quand même qu'on a
des agences régionales de santé et donc
qu'ils ont leur mot à dire en martinique
notamment avec les collectivités sur la
répartition de l'offre de soins je
rappelle également que la martinique est
notée de sentent bon centre hospitalier
et et que alors ce sont des mesures qui
ont diminué notre emploi de santé alors
qu'on en a le plus besoin
bon voilà donc il y avait moyen
meilleure façon de travailler aussi lié
à son travail et la vision parce qu'il
faut aussi une vision politique
est ce que par exemple vous voyez vous
avez l'impression qu'il ya un véritable
partenariat entre la rs et le jeu direct
ou les services de santé de la ctm
je ne sais pas je en toute sincérité
c'est assez opaque
donc je ne sais pas comment il
fonctionne je ne sais pas comment il
faut que je n'entrevois l'impression
d'abord à sion on parle pas elle ne
parle pas simplement d'une vision
commune qu'on parle pas simplement de la
relation entre la ctm et le rs on parle
de cette vision que peut aujourd'hui
avoir peuvent avoir les collectivités et
l'état sur la répartition de l'offre de
soins sur le territoire en l'occurrence
sur le territoire martiniquais
je crois qu'il faut y être attentif
parce que nous avions une bonne
répartition de l'offre de soins il faut
la recouvrer parce qu'il ya encore plus
de besoins que les besoins se sont
affinés et que sur un certain nombre de
spécialités les martiniquais ont besoin
de pouvoir avoir accès à des spécialités
à des soins particuliers
donc voilà donc je pense que ça fait
partie d'une vision politique qu'il faut
amener et peut-être aussi une nouvelle
façon de réagir avec vous le fait
peut-être c'est peut-être ce que vous
apporterez dans le programme pour la
prochaine mandature de la collectivité
territoriales de la martinique puisque
les élections se préparent elles
n'auront probablement pas lieu en mars
mais peut-être en juin
peut-être très probablement les choses
avancent du côté de la fédération
socialiste de la martinique
la fédération socialiste de la
martinique sera de la bataille de la ctm
ça c'est une certitude nous viendrons
portait en effet un nouveau souffle
nous pensons en effet que la martinique
a besoin un de faire à nouveau de la
politique d'avoir de la politique donc
de pouvoir porter de pouvoir comprendre
ce que les politiques portent
en matière d'idéal en matière d' idéal
pour la martinique
un nouveau souffle pour pour construire
également une nouvelle réforme et cette
façon de penser la vie quotidienne des
gens et je crois que la fédération
socialiste a son mot à dire
il faudra compter avec elle car elle
sera de la bataille donc voilà et vous
préconiser de nouvelles méthodes
manifestement non seulement des
nouvelles méthodes mais également un
renouvellement et nous ferons partie de
ce renouvellement
merci béatrice bellay
d'avoir répondu à nos questions mais ses
invités encore une fois bonne année à
toutes et à tous ainsi qu'à notre
technicienne valadine était le viel que
la neige allemande
bonne année le technicien